good afternoon my name is Teresa Ingram
and I am the co-founder of opt-out an
open-source set of tools designed to
help female identifying people engage
with healthy online debate but before I
talk to you about opt-out I'm going to
talk to you about why we need to exist
so most people will recognize this
Friday's the futures is a global climate
action movement fronted by sixteen year
old greater term Berg from Sweden and
now Fridays the futures was not always
the global phenomena that it is today
late August last year greater was out
protesting alone and but it wasn't long
before others started to join her and
one of those was ten year old Lily
Platte from the Netherlands Lily started
to organize her own weekly protests and
it wasn't long before the two were
protesting together that's supposed to
be a picture of the two of them
protesting so as greatest popularity
blossomed and bloomed the hate also
boomed and when Lily jumped in to
greatest defense she received and was
inundated with anti-semitic slurs racist
threats links to porn on her Instagram
and one troll attack that was so severe
her whole family had to change their
mobile phones and these two are not the
only ones we have Havana Chapman
Edmonson on the right hand side as she
has 8 years old and has received racist
threats death threats and even it was
found that by her family that somebody
had tried to contact her who was on the
registered sex offenders list and then
we have Jaime Mogollon who founded the
activist group zero hour
now the other girls have normally the
parents to handle their social media
stuff but Jaime does it herself and
Jaime is gay latina and Jewish
she's inundated with hate and to quote
Jamie from a tweet that she posted last
year like she said I was terrified they
were asking me things like where is my
synagogue and what was creepy was they
got more and more deep and found out
more and more personal information about
me and so I decided to just do like a
really brief search trying to figure out
what was going on with these girls what
was happening and so I don't think the
images are going to work sadly nevermind
and but really these young women are
being targeted online so dishes of media
has opened the door for new forms of
oppression of violence against women and
when those women also happen to be human
rights defenders politically active
vocal or challenging the status quo or
commenting on areas that are seen to be
male this can be even more difficult and
so the UN recognizes that there's a
problem but even for us it opted out
this is not good enough we say that all
female identifying people are
disproportionately suffering abuse
online and when they happen to be
challenging the status quo or if they
happen to have an intersectional
identity be a trans black body weight
you name it the abuse is yet more
intense online misogyny is real and it's
silencing the voices that society so
desperately needs to hear so what are
the social media platforms doing about
it well to give you an example from the
British MP Jess Phillips she reported a
user who was threatening her with rape
threats and this was Twitter's response
so as you can see not very useful the
user was not banned they have been
subsequently banned but initially they
weren't so let's have this larger
conversation then a failure to act me is
that some of our most vulnerable online
are receiving rape and death threats and
as I've already explained with the
example with lily and her family the
boundary the binary
identification between online and
offline is not as clear-cut as it seems
so if big tech are not willing to do
anything about this if they're going to
act as neutral bodies it's up to little
tech to trying to do something about it
so what are we doing how we're going to
do this first step define and conquer so
what is misogyny to opt-out misogyny is
not sexism somebody can like female
don't find people like women but believe
in the power structures that are in
place to keep women in their places
so women belong in the kitchen things
like this and we see misogyny as the law
enforcement of the patriarchy it's also
important for me to tell you why we've
chosen misogyny over sexism and also
misogyny over online gender-based
violence which is the kind of more
broader term which describes all forms
of online violence that's gendered and
that's because opt-out currently is only
working on comments and rhetoric and
it's not working on stopping all forms
of online violence such as daxing which
is the releasing of private details or
revenge porn for example okay so I'm
just going to tell you about some of the
ideas that we've been seeing being
articulated in our data sets so people
tend to either describe men or women as
masculine feminine and there's no
in-betweens and they have intrinsic
characteristics because of their
masculinity or femininity women are
identified with their bodies and by
their body parts and dead naming of
trans women
that's where somebody is referred to by
a name they no longer identify with
claiming that women can't do sport
that's a real favorite of mine and
refocusing the conversation to do with
the male angle agenda or perspective and
I was playing around the data sets and I
ran some random forest scripts just to
try
find some important features of the of
the data and a really important
characteristic of a misogynistic tweet
is this you can't make it up
so sat down with our social scientists
on the team and we went from these ideas
to these groups so we've got seven of
them for now so insult self-explanatory
something that it said just to devalue a
person sexual harassment harassment that
is sexualized in some form be innuendo a
risque joke something like this a threat
of violence anything that has a violent
physical dimension gender essentialism
so this is your men are from Mars Women
are from Venus transmisogyny I'm gonna
explain a little bit more about that
with the example just later on
objectification treating somebody by
their body parts and not as an
individual you know like referring to
them or discussing their worth just
based on how they look things like this
and derailing which is something is
probably a bit easier to explain with
the example later on but it's
essentially just trying to change the
theme of the conversation to something
that the perpetrator feels more
authoritative to talk about so
mansplaining is a great example of dee
railing okay so here are some examples
so transmisogyny often what will happen
with transmisogyny is that a transformer
is referred to by very male
characteristics you know the nice nobody
needs their and these are some of the
hashtags that are used often
objectification and dee railing so i've
already mentioned about the mound
splaining another example of dee railing
is something called a mob attack which
is where a user's social media feed is
flooded with messages be them banal or
be them totally sexist racist
threatening whatever and this can not
just last for hours or a day the some of
the worst cases I've seen have been
months and what this does is it renders
the user in able to really use
social media how how they how they
should be able to so it's also important
to just mention quickly that currently
the model that we're using is not a
multi classifier these are kind of our
academic groups just so we can
understand the face of the beast that is
online misogyny so that's online
misogyny for opt-out so our solution it
out we're hoping to put a stop to the
silencing nature of online misogyny the
general data protection regulation gdpr
has changed our lives on social media
platforms we have the right to be
forgotten to see what is being collected
about us and to opt out if we wish but
the abuse that female identifying people
are receiving online is not optional we
see opt out as an extension of the gdpr
that also upholds the human rights of
these individuals allowing them to
engage with respectful online debate
once more so we have an open-source set
of tools designed to help any female
identifying person get back to the
online spaces that they've been chased
out from and our main tool is our
browser extension that works essentially
like an ad blocker but filters out
online misogyny instead of adverts but
we're also much more than that
we're holding workshops that are
bringing together female don't find
people to not only offer support but act
in a form of protest that enough is
enough and by doing this we not only
provide a valuable resource for these
people but we also are able to identify
needed technical infrastructure ensuring
that our tech is community driven as it
possibly can be we also have a awesome
website and which I'll get to in a
second and we are trying to develop our
own antidote to Silicon Valley KPI so
other KPIs that Mezrich measure
participation measure things like number
of users or number of shares what we're
trying to do is to develop KPIs that may
things like diversity and inclusivity
and health of online discussion and
finally we're just being as loud and
proud as we possibly can be so this is
our website our website is inspired by
Egyptian based NGO harass map harassed
map is a website where you can go and
submit anonymously details of a physical
incident harassment that you've received
and it's mapped it's put onto a virtual
map opt-out version you can submit
anonymous details of an online incident
that you have received and that data is
then stored studied and feeds the models
that are tools depend on we're also
showing transparently how our data is
were being how the data is being used
and usage statistics and our KPIs on the
website so we can try to show female
then find people how their submission is
helping their online sisters and help to
fuel the movement finally in the long
distance future we hope to have a
virtual harass map which will enable
FEMA identifying people to navigate the
murky waters of online life as best they
can
and finally our browser extension so our
browser extension just works with a
simple binary classifier sentiment
analyzer sat on a server somewhere what
happens is the page loads the tweets are
sent to the backend the model evaluates
them returned to score and if it deems
it misogynistic they're removed and if
not they stay and if there's an image
attached to the comment then the image
is also removed so simple not too
difficult and well the browser
extensions course have got a lot more
coming if that's what it is currently
but there's a lot more to be added to it
so there is going to be automatic
reporting of misogynistic tweets they
will anything that is deemed
misogynistic will be automatically sent
to the moderators to be
to be checked over and also the browser
extension and an opt-out in general is
consents not censorship focus what's
going to happen is that the browser
central will have its own local instance
of the model that you can supply
feedback to because we're not we're not
going to get it right each time and
we're not going to get it right for
everybody and so currently what we have
is everything apart from the local
instance model and the current models
that we have built still has a lot of
work to do but luckily we have a fuel a
few tricks in our tools in our toolbox
to help us with that so the ticket to
any successful supervised learning
problem is a really good labelled data
set but where do you obtain a
misogynistic or a feminist data set we
tried many different places and we had
to make our own so first we started by
searching for key terms on Twitter and
cameltoe being a really important key
term to use if you want to find
misogynistic comments and but then we
found that our search was as good as we
were mean or as good as we were creative
so we decided to then search for
politicians names and any other
outspoken women online for example zoe
quinn the games developer who is a
victim of gamergate and i suggest that
you go read about that if you don't know
what that is and so we ended up with too
many comments too much data and it was
very diluted so then we reached out to
our academic friends and zurich cuisine
very kindly gave us his dataset which
was developed using these search terms
you can see here and which are to do
with my kitchen rules which is an
australian cooking TV show and also the
final data set that we were able to
obtain is the automatic misogyny
identification
to set from Elisabetta faceny and this
is quite a new dataset for us so I'm not
entirely sure how she collected it and
developed it but opted in to opt out and
we'll let you know and we know so we
have the data great but it's not labeled
and after a disastrous round of our own
attempts to annotate we decided to go
snorkeling on the great advice of one of
our team members and Ryder and I mean
our agree ability score was so low that
I was wondering whether we should really
continue the project at all so this was
really a savior and what has who's heard
of snorkel cool so snorkel is a
framework for multi task week
supervision essentially what you do is
write some labeling functions which are
then used to augment your data set so
you manually label some tweets some
comments and then you write some rules
and these rules can take these forms
regex being the most popular for example
these are some that we wrote as the rape
flesh is a online dialect that's used to
attack women but I'll going more into
that later
and then you evaluate you see how well
your rules accurately predict the label
the comments that you've labeled and
then you also see how much conflict
there is between the different labeling
functions and you end up with a table
like this and the to it really important
comment columns are the empirical
accuracy and coverage you want your
empirical accuracy to be above at least
not 0.5 because that's the accuracy of
your label to your labeling function to
get it right and then coverage to be as
high as possible
and from this snorkel lens a builds a
generative model and that becomes your
labeling model and what this does is it
produces labels for unlabeled data and
you have your golden ticket great but
this wasn't the end for us we reach out
to somebody who wrote a brilliant
tutorial on snorkel called Abraham and
what's come from this is that we've
begun a wonderful partnership with
sculpt and sculpt is essentially a web
app version of snorkel and what this
does is it allows our it not only gets
rid of the labeling bottleneck but it
allows our domain experts our social
scientists to distill their knowledge
directly into opt out I'm no longer the
middle person between the data
scientists and the social scientists
they can sit there understand what
they're doing understand the labeling
their label functions and the impact of
the different ones and which ones fit
and which ones don't
the best thing is though that it allows
us to mess up we can change our mind
about misogyny we can change our
different categories and it doesn't
matter instead of taking weeks maybe
even months to relay all the data set it
takes days and so we have now a data set
of about 20,000 labeled comments and
we've just got some initial like initial
results and these are the 20 top curse
words found on internet on in internet
language and as you can see there's
already a gender difference in the
language between non misogynistic and
misogynistic it's a very similar sort of
thing here so here I all I did was find
the use spacey dependency trees to try
and find
the subject and verb of a sentence and
filtered it based on whether the subject
was male or female and these are the
verbs attached to it I know I'm really
trying to get out is it that already
just very basic labeling schema and
stuff we're already seeing gendered
language differences in the gendered
language so now we have a data set we
can start playing around with some cool
modeling stuff and actually what's
working best for us currently is our
logistic regression model that we built
in sculpt but that's probably because we
haven't got around to really tuning our
deep learning models we also have a
hunch that state retaining like deep
deep learning architecture won't really
cut it for tweets because they're too
short and so this is what we have so far
but really this is this is really really
basic and not going to stay like this
for long
so I really urge you to just check out
this repo this is where a lot of data
science is happening because where we're
going next is looking at graph
convolutional networks trying to develop
or trying to understand the influence of
different users on our ability to
classify whether something is
misogynistic or not and as I mentioned
about the rape flesh before we're also
going to look at treating misogyny as a
dialect and after being inspired by a
talk they'd heard here at PyCon also how
to model meaning and I need to find the
person who gave that talk and taught
them a bit more about it okay so where
we're at currently so we currently have
a MVP browser extension an MVP website
and we're being active we're getting out
there talking to people being out there
in the community but we always are in
need of more people our website is in
need of a serious makeover and this is
where we're going we've just completed
our first round of funding applications
for the rest of 2019 we're just going to
be looking at improving what we've got
and beginning the implementation of the
local model
in 2020 we see ourselves going
multi-platform multilingual and
eventually building the virtual harassed
map but with anything like this is
important not only to talk about what
we're doing and why but who we are and
we're a range of people from data nerds
to social scientists but what's a
commonality between us all is that we
won't let hate win our vision is we want
to champion women back into the online
worlds have been chased out from support
them and their voices while still
protecting them and holding the
perpetrators accountable online misogyny
is real and it's silencing the voices
that society so desperately needs to
hear
let's opt out and well thank you very
much how it's a fascinating talk as well
and have any questions from the audience
that we can cool sure and catch a road
to put their hands up quite quite tall
so I know where to go after hey thank
you for an excellent talk and excellent
in sheer - I personally would like to
thank you for setting up op dot and
looking out for other people in online
so I kind of have two doubts I rinse it
as doubt maybe one of them is cessation
so first out is that when you say or the
browser extensions that opt out produced
does it only filter female identifying
online misogyny or is it gender unbiased
the way I see online abuses Internet is
a harsh place and everyone will be a
victim eventually that's what I feel so
is it going to be only redacting the
female identifying online misogyny or is
it gender unbiased and the second is
kind of a suggestion since you guys are
basically reacting the online misogyny
when the extension is activated in
browser extension you can get the
usernames and reported
to the government or even to the tool
like Twitter or Facebook so that they
can ban the people because at least the
country where I am from we have online
rules and stuff so if you do come in
some Ibiza stuff you can get even
arrested so is it possible that you can
create a tool where you can
automatically report them to the
respective organizations or governments
to take action on them so the first
question as I understood it was are we
just focusing on FEMA identifying
misogyny and I think we're just focusing
on misogyny it doesn't really I think it
doesn't really matter who it's coming
from as such an ease is it's
gender-neutral
almost I mean it's yeah I mean it all it
is is law enforcement of the patriarchy
so even if it's another woman saying oh
you should be in the kitchen that's
misogyny and secondly um as far as I
understood again is there going to be
some way to automatically report people
hold them accountable yes that's so that
was supposed to be there in the MVP
already
the problem is in every other country
apart from Germany that automatic
reporting function is really easy to do
but in Germany for Twitter it's a legal
document that's taken a little bit
longer but that's because we can't we
don't just want to hide the problem we
want to hold people accountable for it
yeah thank you very much and thank you
MK see if anyone else has a question
could you also put your hands up for the
moment so I can see where to go
afterwards okay does it only work with
English or have you included other
languages as well we will we certainly
well I'm so and righto who gave this
brilliant talk just before on does hate
sound the same in all languages is a key
member of opt out so this is you know
we're definitely going to do this sooner
rather than later because because
misogyny exists across but as soon as we
transfer from different language is also
about transferring the cultural
understanding as well so it's it's not
even just as simple as retraining some
models so it will take time but
we're growing we can do it and thank you
and there anymore any more questions
I think was a one hand over here as this
one to us how big is your data says how
long have you been collecting so our
working the one that we're most happy
with currently is about 20,000 but we've
got too many comments we've got too many
yeah it's something like it's over 26
million comments so yeah too many and
just before I go to the top and I
actually had one question myself oh no
and that a lot of and they're kind of
misogynistic or and I kind of hate field
languages sometimes kind of reclaimed by
the communities to which their hate is
like directed and so I wondered
especially things like the browser
extension do you have a way of managing
what might be like a potentially false
positive you know as faults something
that's falsely identified as being hate
speech when in fact is kind of protest
the gangster it's like a reclamation of
yeah yeah um that's a really good
question I think my idea is to have
something that is not just looking at
the content of the tweet but also the
conversation so who is this comment
coming from and and hopefully that will
be um make it easier to classify between
when something is intended as negative
and when something is more of a protest
but ya know that's a really good point
and we're not sure yet further on the
very much okay further questions damn
yeah
um you mentioned that the browser plugin
would be automatically reporting tweets
is that in line with the Terms of
Service of Twitter can you automate
reports I haven't seen I see the counter
I haven't seen that we can't so like I
said though and like a an opt-out is
really about protesting in activism as
well so if we ruffle some Twitter
feathers I'm fine with that
hi I have a question because I moderated
social media and I know that but so for
public fears some things can be allowed
yeah did you consider that because to
protect female public figures could be
difficult compared to protect just
females like regular women I think we'd
have to look more I wasn't aware so now
we have it so yeah we'll bear that in
mind yeah and thanks for your talk very
inspiring I have two questions is it a
business you mentioned your father
raised money so if it is what's your
model and the second one is so you have
a definition of misogyny with which I
personally agree with but you know how
do you deal with going somewhere and
people telling you actually it's not
misogyny it's just how we do things here
it's part of our culture you know with
traditional we're conservative and
you're liberal and you know you bring
your hippie ideas you know how do you do
is deal with this you know come answer
the second question first we just tell
them not to download it it's fine they
don't need to use it and the first
question so we have ideas for turning
this into a into a business we can
sell an API subscription-based for um
say like tinder for example tips when we
eventually do things like you know like
removing dick pics and stuff like this
we can sell our services to dating apps
also another idea is selling an API -
you know you have like MSN chats with
customer service representatives online
they get a lot of abuse as well
so developing an API to help protect
those people as well thanks and just one
final question
thank you my question goes away from
online to offline to events like they
swim and I wonder if you reflect about
events like pi data or the general
community of data signs that the vast
majority well I read as male and still
in this in this talk I perceive the the
room as much emptier than in most other
talks so I think III don't want to go as
far as asking whether is misogyny also
represented here it certainly is but if
you try to develop like let me call them
tools on a battlefield how do you or do
you also work on encouraging those who
are affected by by misogyny to like get
on the boat and develop with you know
it's the question clear as as far as I
understood it how are we doing anything
to help to help get rid of the misogyny
within computing or tech and some didn't
understand yes also the no I just
thought it may be a very hard in this
community to actually just find people
who are affected to join you developing
you can you could probably get a bunch
of males to work with you on the tool
but that will not be the same so
scarcity is in our favor actually
because there are very few topics like
this
you know there are women in this
community so you know so they all come
and they go come help so but also to
answer the question that I thought you
asked as well we're really trying to
make it as beginner-friendly and trying
to allowing people to do things that are
outside their comfort zones and career
change as well as much as possible so
yeah we're really trying to encourage as
many first contributors women changing
careers all this stuff into our open
source stuff as much possible well
that's brilliant thank you very much to
everyone who's come along and can we
have a big thing thank you see both of
our speakers today
[Music]